what's the one gift you desperately
wanted as a kid but never got o a puppy
a and and you know what I heard through
the door I was a naughty child I heard
my mom arranging to go and get a puppy
and it never
came but my it was even worse for my
sister who went to go and choose a puppy
and she chose one thinking that we were
going to get it but my mom said it was
pooing too much so it never arrived at
the house are you going to get a dog
well we we just did BuzzFeed puppies you
know on BuzzFeed you play with puppies
and you get interviewed and there was I
there I talk about two Souls meeting
this I've never seen anything like it
just came to me is it available there a
little boy yeah and I think he's called
Skippy no it's his character's name
character's name in the movie by the way
this is so Bashar I'm telling you
there's magic happening today go get
that puppy I'm going to go right now
nothing is life with the dog is the
best